[MUSIC PLAYING]
RON KAUK: I've been
around the sun 60 times.
My friend Kenji Hakuta is
one of our board members.
And in his culture, that
means that I've been reborn.
And I love the way that
sounds, because it kind of
feels like it.
It's an exciting time to try
to understand your life story
and what you can
do to help others.
So that's where I'm at.
But I was fortunate to be
born in Redwood City in 1957.
Ended up going to
school at Carlmont High
School in Belmont.
Like she was saying, in 1971,
because of the adults that
had set up a class for us
called mountaineering class,
that we were gluing on
rocks and wood blocks
in our multipurpose
room, creating a climbing
wall in 1971.
That's so interesting
to think about.
And I'm so fortunate those
adults were in that place
to help a guy like
me that wasn't
that interested in school.
To sit in a classroom with
a desk and all lined up just
wasn't working for me.
I was staring out the
window up at the hills,
going, man, I wish
I was out there.
But fortunately, they had
that mountaineering class.
So we would do these little
activities around the school--
rappel off the
building and all this.
They also offered us a
20 day backpacking trip.
1972, I think I was going to
be a sophomore that summer.
We went up to northern
Yosemite for 20 days.
And during that 20
days, they gave us
three days by ourselves.
They'd be accused of abuse now.
There's no doubt about it.
What are you doing with
those kids out there?
So for three days, I had my-- an
adult will come over and check
on you once in a while.
I had my campfire.
Light flickered off the boat,
night stars over your head,
nobody telling you what to do.
How exciting is that
for a 14-year-old?
Also during that trip,
they offered rock climbing.
And like I say, it is 1972,
so the word extreme was not
buzzing in the air.
It was conservatively
approached,
like the art of
protecting yourself,
responsible adults setting
up ropes for us kids,
tying the knot securely.
Just climbing these
little climbs.
But funny thing that happened
that day was our ex-Marine
coach that we all
really respected--
because he had a handle on
all of us, amazingly enough--
bet anybody a
milkshake if they could
make this particular climb.
I always tell this story
because it's so significant.
I won that milkshake
off a respected adult
after 20 days in the mountains,
three days by myself.
And I always said, at
that point a way of life
was laid out for me.
I could see it clearly,
which is interesting
because the imagination
of a 14-year-old
is very powerful if the adults
point you in a good direction.
That's part of it.
So then by 17, it was climbing
El Capitan, but responsibly.
We understood the system of
how to protect ourselves.
So the lessons that
are coming through now
are so profound that you
need to take everything
you need in a haul bag-- your
food, your water, your shelter.
And you're up there
for days, and you
have to respect that environment
of the vertical world.
You have to have the skills
for survival, basically.
And then you recognize how
important water and food are.
So if you're passing a
water bottle to your partner
1,000 feet off the
ground, you say,
make sure you have
a good grip on that.
Can you imagine
the story of water?
That's something we want to work
on in the future for our kids,
is have a real
understanding about water.
So these are all
the lessons that
were coming through it,
all those formidable years
of teenage--
to have these
initiations almost.
They're like rites of passage.
They're these
challenges we need.
So much can happen
between 14 and 21.
between those years.
This is the environment
I'm in, right here.
I always say if you can
see the beauty in nature,
you'll see the
beauty in yourself.
So here's me at 15
years old, completely
influenced by guys like
Yvon Chouinard, the founder
of Patagonia and Royal Robbins.
And what I have
hanging off my shoulder
there is called hex nuts--
clean climbing.
So they were promoting
clean climbing at that time
as we started, because
they were using pitons,
banging them back and forth
in the rock leaving scars.
So Yvon and guys like
him that cared enough
started this trend
towards clean climbing.
So I was already getting the
hint on respect for nature.
So I want you to see this
big move I was making here
up at Lovers' Leap near Tahoe.
Do you see that?
Let me show you again.
I just stood up on that.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a huge move for 15 years
old, going up a 5.9 climb.
But again, it was
so conservative.
We had to place
our gear carefully.
And this is another
exciting thought
about how the mind develops--
being responsible for yourself
and learning the art
of protecting yourself.
So again, things
accelerate pretty quick.
At that age, I think there's so
much intelligence in our senses
to adapt to what's
in front of us
when we're shown
that it ended up
where we did this climb,
Midnight Lightning, in 1978.
In fact, we showed
one of the guys
that had been around longer than
us where the chalk was going.
He thought we were
just joking him.
He said, that's funny.
You guys put chalk up there
to make me think you did that.
So this climb-- the exciting
thing about this climb,
it's in the center of Camp 4,
the National Historic Register
climbers' campsite.
And people come from
all over the world
to make this connection
with that climb.
I've met people from
Japan, Australia, anywhere.
And part of their journey
was to do that climb.
There's another one
called Thriller.
And did this in 1984.
And this was a
climb that everyone
was trying to get their hand on
that hold I have right there.
But no one had ever done it.
And I imagine-- I mean, I
got my hand on that hold.
And then I thought,
well, that's it.
That's the end of the problem.
I'll just jump off.
But I said, wait a minute.
Let me check above.
And I was searching
for any little hold,
and there was some moss.
And I popped the moss off
so there was the tiniest
little edge there.
And I jumped back down.
I go, it'll go.
This will be another level
above Midnight Lightning.
There's something
very significant
in this symbolic idea of
that little edge being hidden
under that moss, that it would
take you to the next step,
to another level up.
So this was called Thriller.
And this environment that
you're in is so profound.
And that's, again, why I
feel that for human beings,
we need to be around
nature to know who we are,
to be inspired about who
we are, and to understand
our responsibility
to natural laws.
Because there are natural
laws that govern the world,
that are higher than human laws.
We need our human laws
to keep ourselves intact.
But if we don't follow
the natural laws,
air gets polluted.
Water gets polluted.
And the future
doesn't look good.
So this is the environment.
I've been here.
I love that tree right there,
trying to imagine how old it is
and how it grew
from a little seed.
This is on El Capitan.
You might recognize
from the videos,
that rockfall fell
right behind me.
This is a route
called the Zodiac.
So that's the east
buttress over there,
where we just had
that big rockfall.
So again, we recognize
the vulnerability of us.
This was on our first descent
on El Capitan called New Jersey
Turnpike.
It goes up the east
coast of what they
call the North American Wall.
What a place to
spend your youth.
And that's why I'm so
adamant about our kids
and youthful enthusiasm, the
ones that are walking around
down the streets
trying to figure out
what to do with themselves.
So like Yvon Chouinard
said once-- he said,
"Climbing saved my life."
That's a profound statement.
Climbing saved our life.
And to reflect on these ages,
this stage of life in my teens,
to think about being able to do
this route called Astro Man--
maybe some of you
have heard of that.
It's on the east face
of Washington Column.
And we were primed exactly
perfect for this climb
to do the first free ascent.
We were coming in at about 511
C, if you know these numbers.
And never fell on it.
Of course, we're climbing
with ropes and all that.
But to be on this kind
of aesthetic granite
and feel yourself a part
of the flow of that cliff
is hard to even put
words on, actually.
But I think it does lend itself
to this intimate relationship
with nature that can, again,
inspire the humanness in you,
the senses in us.
This is how we were
first doing it.
You can see on that picture
there's a cot hanging there.
This is before they
invented the actual porter
ledge, if you've heard of that,
for sleeping up on El Cap.
That was some Navy bunk that my
friend thought was a great idea
to bring along to sleep on.
And that used to catch the wind.
You'd be pulling it up
the wall, and the wind
would be slapping it all around.
But became kind of dangerous.
Again, from 14, the
20-day backpack trip,
to when I was 21 years
old, I headed back
into the mountains of Pakistan.
After learning all the
disciplines of climbing,
the bouldering, the one-pitch
climbs, the free climbs,
the artificial aid
climbs on El Capitan,
going to the Canadian
Rockies, doing ice
climbing-- all that was
put into this expedition
to Pakistan in
1979, where we had
29 porters from the
local area to walk back
for seven days with us.
We walked past villages
that were self-sufficient.
I was trying to convince people
of the good boulders they
had around.
So our base camp
was at 14,000 feet.
We had a 2,000-foot ice
gully to get to the base
of our 3,000-foot rock climb.
I always make a joke.
Right now, if some
documentary filmmakers
came and asked me,
"Ron, we'd like
to go back and recreate
that and go to that climb
and make a big documentary.
We'll pay you $5 million
dollars," I'd say,
no, I'm good.
[LAUGHTER]
That's why I have
so much respect
for youthful enthusiasm.
There was four of. us.
We had six haul bags.
We melted snow on
ledges for water.
We were on the wall for 10
days to get to the summit.
Once you got to the
summit, it was a pinnacle.
And you could stand
there and look around.
You could see up to
K2, the second highest
mountain in the world.
And the only way down
was the way you came up.
Big adventure and
no rescue possible.
You were so on your own.
There's someone up there.
Uli Biaho, it was called
in the Trango Valley.
It's funny to even see
yourself standing there.
It's hard to believe
that even happened.
Which led me back to Yosemite.
And like she was saying, I've
been so fortunate in the timing
to be able to do a
lot of first ascents
on such aesthetic,
beautiful rock.
This is in Tuolumne Meadows,
a route called Peace.
So I share some of
the rock climbing,
because it's been
profound as my teacher,
as a way to develop
myself and understand
the experiences,
like I was saying,
and try to learn
something from them.
But ultimately, what it's
gave me is a sense of place.
I feel 100% connected
to Yosemite.
In fact, one of my transitions
of time was when I hit 40.
And there's a few things
that were going on.
But the one thing that
was profound for me
is that I was
coming into Yosemite
on my motorcycle, a little
Honda 250, just cruising.
And I went past this
thing called Fern Spring.
And I was coming
around the corner.
It's kind of a
little blind corner,
but you could see Bridal
Veil Falls with the rainbow.
And I was just looking at it.
And all of a sudden,
I looked down.
There was a car coming
at me the wrong way.
And I was just like, hoo.
My whole body went
into slow motion.
And I had this thought.
Get out of the way.
I moved to the side,
because there was
other cars coming along, too.
And I got past the car, but my
leg hit the bumper and broke.
And I rolled past
it and fell over.
And I was laying there in
the road with a broken leg
after all those years.
Even 19, went climbing
without a rope when
you're going to live forever.
Been through all
these risky things.
And here, that happened.
And the crazy thing
that happened two weeks
before that is I played a victim
in a first responder course
exactly like that.
That's just nuts, right?
I was laying there,
and the paramedics say,
you'll be all right.
I'm like, yeah, yeah,
it's just my leg.
And I go, man, it's just what
I was saying two weeks ago
in that first responder class.
How am I supposed to
make sense of that?
But anyways, it was such
a shock to my system to--
I don't know if anybody's
broke a bone, but it's intense.
So then I had an
experience after I
left for six weeks, healing.
I had a cast all up my leg.
And I had a walking cast.
And I happened to
be standing in what
they called Valley View, where
you can see all of Yosemite
perfectly with the
river right there.
No one was around,
full moon night.
It was kind of cloudy, so it
accentuated the landscape.
And I was just looking there,
reflecting and thinking
about all the years in
Yosemite, all the people
I've met, climbs I've done,
swimming in the river.
Just the whole thing.
I kept looking at that scene
and feeling the experience.
And I was like, poof.
This crazy profound
thought was I had
no separation from the place.
I felt completely connected.
My eyes started watering in the
sense of I found my way home.
And I think that's
the potential we have
when we understand how
to commune with nature.
We feel at home.
And I think we're always
looking for that now.
And why do 5 million
people come to Yosemite?
I'm still trying to wrap
my mind around that.
So that's just a little thing
to share there that probably
got me on the next phase.
And not long after, we
started this nonprofit.
And so like I say,
this time, it's
really fun to help the kids.
Because I say to these
guys all the time,
you guys really make me think.
You make me consider what's
your future going to be.
This up at Cathedral Lake.
So again, the beauty
is so profound,
and that water is super cold.
And you wanted to
go up there anyway.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Being in nature
makes me feel like
a real, regular human being.
What I mean by that is
by helping others out
of the kindness of
our hearts, not having
to go against anyone,
it makes me feel
like I'm in a different world.
- I clear my mind from any
personal issues or stress
and enjoy the beauty
of the earth that has
been left in its natural state.
I feel free, like there's
nothing that can go wrong
and that we belong in
environments like that.
This last trip we
went to Mirror Lake.
And on certain
parts of the trail,
we had to take our shoes off and
walk barefoot through puddles
and gravel passages.
It made me think of how
people walked around
about 1,000 years ago.
- It's just great to
be in nature like that.
- It's a good way to clear
your mind and a peaceful place.
[END PLAYBACK]
RON KAUK: Those are some of our
youngsters from juvenile hall.
We do our little circle talks.
And we recorded their voices.
Uh-oh.
I knew that was going to happen.
So we're learning from them.
And we want them to be
able to express themselves.
And that's what, back
from my rock climbing--
I got to express myself
all those years learning
to climb a rock.
And so now you can
see with our youth,
we want them to be able
to use their voice.
And we should all have the
right to use our voice.
That's back to
that communication.
So I feel like when we learn
to commune with nature,
we can learn to communicate,
if you're following me.
I mean, we are nature.
We are water.
So when I was talking about
watching those sunrises
by the water, if I just
let the water-- keep
listening to the water and
keep listening to the water
and I just use my imagination,
I say, I am water.
And that should
sound crazy to you,
because we put water in
this little bottle right now
and sell it.
I always joke with the people.
I show a movie every Friday and
Saturday night up in Yosemite
called "Return to Balance:
A Climber's Journey"
and always bring up
the fact that this
is one of our high water years.
There was so much
snow and so much
water flowing over
the waterfalls.
How many gallons
per minute could
have been flowing over those
waterfalls 24 hours a day?
And yet we go over
and buy a bottle of it
in a plastic bottle
for $4 or $3.
I said, what would that water
be worth in 20, 30 years?
I like to think like that.
I just play around.
I want to open this up to
questions, too, at any time,
if you guys want
to help me along.
Because it's a lot to cover.
It's interesting to try to cover
40 years of rock climbing--
or 35, 40-- and then 10
years of doing this nonprofit
and then trying to grasp
the potential that we have
to make a difference within
the outdoor education realm
and in the public school
realm and then for all of us
to truly take a deep
look at where we are at.
So these kids, they know where
they're at, some of the guys
that we're with.
They're locked up.
And so they go
into adult prison.
And it's just an impressive
story to grasp the history.
Because I say to these guys,
you know, 200 years ago
this prison didn't exist.
None of this was even
happening, not here, anyway.
So you can probably read that.
When I first went to Yosemite,
it felt like I was in heaven.
So I think there's
a lot of potential
to help our youth get some
time instead of do time.
And I think that's
what all of us
are looking for is
to have more time.
Because I heard it said--
I don't know who was saying it.
[INAUDIBLE] or
somebody said there
was going to be a
point in history
where we became too busy.
Became too busy to
realize what was going on.
We hear the ice
caps are melting.
Our Sierras, the
trees, are all dying.
Millions of trees have
died up in our Sierra.
And I don't say this
to be like doomsday.
I just think it's
all interesting.
How are we affecting things?
"You're somebody who has
affected my life by letting
me see new things and
realize that nature is
a beautiful and sacred place."
We gave him an A-plus for that.
"In nature, I feel like
the weight of my shoulders
is released.
It feels like a gift."
These are profound statements.
I won't read them all.
So this is our classroom.
"This is our
potential to hopefully
have a little story
rewrite at this point
to bring some
compassion, appreciation,
self-respect, equality.
Everything that was
ever good I think
you could learn from
watching a river."
This is kind of fun.
"I look forward to going to
Yosemite with you and hiking.
I appreciate you giving
us a different path
and some type of freedom."
That's one of our Boys
and Girls Club's girls.
Nature is a great playground.
And maybe some of you
have come across that book
by Richard Loud, "Last
Child in the Woods:
Saving our Children from
Nature Deficit Disorder."
It's a book about that thick--
good to reference.
This is my favorite quote.
"When I go to Yosemite, I
feel like I can honestly
be who I am.
I can escape my problems
in a healthy way.
"I take that first breath
of fresh mountain air,
and I inhale nothing but
good, positive energy.
And when I exhale, my problems
are released out of my body.
I love the beauty of Yosemite.
It encourages me and
gives me hope that I can
make my life beautiful, too."
That's a heavy-duty statement
from this one young woman
that was in foster care, group
homes, and in juvenile hall.
And she goes, I just
love it up here.
Pretty awesome.
So we're called a
small nonprofit,
but I think we're
doing very big things.
And we want our
big things to get
into the mainstream of helping
our kids back to nature,
helping us all back to that.
So maybe as we're all
getting a group mind here,
we could think, how
could we all do that?
How could we all make
a commitment right now
in some way, shape,
or form of our mind
to take one of your kids out
or other kids out into nature
and go for a walk and
get to know each other
and start circle talks and
ask them how they're feeling?
That's the experience I've
been having in juvenile hall.
Because when you first meet
each other, it's like this.
And they would admit it, too.
"Yeah, when you first met
us, we were kind of stiff."
I go, yeah, maybe a little bit.
But through trust and
respect, the basic elements
of being a healthy human being,
we started a good relationship.
And that's why I'm saying
Sacred Rok is committed
to relationships and
building relationships that
have to do with
family, community,
but nature especially.
Because I think our power--
I don't know how to
use this word power.
But I think power--
the earth seems powerful.
The sun seems powerful.
The ocean is powerful.
Yosemite feels like
a whole new world.
It clears your mind and gives
you a great feeling and joy.
This is everything we all want.
And you don't really
have to buy it.
One of the great
things we get to do
is trail work up in Yosemite.
We remove this asphalt.
One guy was pointing out
that asphalt is two
words for blame.
And it's toxic material.
And so I was looking
at these trails
forever, because
there's water flowing.
And they always erode, and
the little pieces of asphalt
go in the river.
So us guys-- the
assistant superintendent
at the time-- we were talking.
And he said, man, we
need to get rid of that.
I go, hey, our
guys will do that.
So we got to doing
this community service
work for quite a while.
I want to continue to do it.
So these guys, they
love this kind of work
because you can thug around
and help the place out.
This is Lamar Henderson.
He's our voice in Merced.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- As someone who's involved
in the juvenile justice system
here in Merced County,
what impact do you
think the Sacred Rok program
is having on the kids who
are incarcerated?
- Well, in my position as the
Chair for the Merced County
Juvenile Justice Delinquency
Prevention Commission,
I see Sacred Rok as being one
of the tremendous opportunities
in youth enrichment experiences
for our most fragile and most
valued youth.
Having an experience--
I never get
used to seeing children
through little windows.
And I'm always kind
of taken back at,
what were the life experiences
that brought this child here.
And I know for some, this
is the most stable place
in their life.
So to have an opportunity
to participate in Sacred Rok
and experience
education nature's way
and to be in Yosemite,
this awesome, majestic
place that people come to
from all around the world--
and many of our youth right
here in our community rarely
ever see it.
So to take this experience
of being in juvenile hall,
of being in a situation
that seems so pessimistic
and hopeless and take
them to Yosemite and see
the transformation from the time
they come out of the facility
to the drive all the way to
Yosemite and everything that
comes with that-- the aesthetic
appeal, the change in climate,
change in air--
and see how that has a
transformational effect
on our youth--
I think it plant seeds of
hope that, man, I belong here.
And this is a place
where I can go.
And it's accessible to me.
And you don't have to
be rich, and you don't
have to be highly educated.
And you don't have to
be all these things
that we think have to accompany
health and wellness that they
have access to.
So I think introducing new,
healthier, and accessible
opportunities for youth
is critically important,
especially for our youth
in the institution.
[END PLAYBACK]
RON KAUK: Yeah.
I love Lamar.
He does such amazing work.
He's in other things,
like All Dads Matter
But he said something that
stuck in my mind once.
He said, "Merced needs
a divine intervention."
I thought that sounded
kind of like, whoa.
Man, that's heavy.
But this is where we're at--
I mean, really.
Say if you get to drift between
these worlds from Yosemite
to coming here--
it's interesting to build
the bridges between them.
And that's what we're
trying to do with Merced
is build that bridge
between Yosemite and Merced
and get a stronger
sense of education.
They're even building an
outdoor campus up in Yosemite.
Nature Bridge is another
nonprofit up there.
They're building a $57
million outdoor campus.
And we're hoping
to have influence
on that somehow to bring back
the intimacy and the respect
to connect with nature--
not just scientifically,
but with the wisdom.
"Sacred Rok is
about facilitating
the ceremony of nature.
Everything we do together
is based on respect."
We're totally getting
get back to the basics.
And I think that's what's so
profound about being human
and about the natural world is
if we can simplify, have time
to be simple--
the simplicity of just being.
And that's why we
say "facilitating
the ceremony of nature."
We just go for walks, and
we're in these environments.
And like I said, as humans, we
have our own eyes to see it.
We have our own
ears to hear it--
smells, taste, touch.
Get these senses engaged.
And I'm as motivated
as Google, personally.
I'm as motivated as
Google to bring this
into the light of the
future for education.
Because these kids,
they are our future.
And it's all about the
kids, in my point of view,
and their education.
And these guys know
where they're at.
That's why they can
say profound things,
like, "No matter how bad
the day is and the struggles
you're going through,
it's up to you
to make it the best
day you ever had."
That's an amazing comment.
These are guys
that are locked up.
I don't even know
how they do it.
I went into one of
those little cells once.
And we were making
a little film.
When the guy closed the
door, I'm like, dang.
The thought of having
to wait for someone
to open that door for
you freaks me out.
But then some people
might be freaked out
to be 1,000 feet up on
El Cap tied with a rope.
So it makes you
wonder, doesn't it?
But I think it's
really exciting,
our work and our
connection with kids
and the beauty of Yosemite.
Because it's so unlimited
in the possibilities.
And that's what I mean
about Google or any
of these big companies now.
They've came up with
ideas, a group of people,
and they went somewhere with it.
And to see the intelligence
that we have-- but how will we
use that intelligence in the
future to think intelligently?
How to bring ourselves back
into balance and the world
back into balance and
break these barriers down,
like that wall that there's
a guy that wants to build
between Mexico and here?
These walls-- what
are these walls?
It seems absurd that we
have so much intelligence
and we use it to sabotage each
other and do all these things.
That's what you learn about
going to juvenile hall.
You think, where
did this come from?
What's the history to this?
How well do we know our history?
Are we taught
their true history?
Do we know our
ancestral lineage?
Do we know that we're
all indigenous people
from the planet?
Do we know that we're
made up of the earth?
Have we forgotten these things?
And if we forget them, then
you can see the results.
Because that's what's
happening today.
We're recognized as
the lost generation.
But I say this with compassion
and respect and appreciation
for the healing that is going to
take place one way or another.
This is my campsite.
This is in the morning--
like I said, the 10 summers.
And you know that
expression, it dawned on you?
It really exists.
It will dawn on you to see the
profound reality of the new day
coming, especially when you get
up when the stars are still up.
And you can watch the
track of the moon, too.
I'll see the moon as a
sliver with the sunrise.
And then the full moon will be
setting as the sun is rising.
To watch this
process is amazing.
And to see the sun starts in the
east and ends up in the west.
But they tell me that
the sun doesn't move
and that the earth turns.
That's true, right?
That's amazing.
We are living in
an amazing reality.
That's reality.
But we've created an illusion
that we call reality,
so we forget about the
reality of the sun not moving
and the earth going
around the sun.
How does the earth know
how to go around the sun?
How does it know?
How does your heart
know how to beat?
This is the good news channel.
I'm just trying
to share it here.
I love being inside
this building, sharing
these thoughts and feelings.
Because it brings
more power to us
as human beings to think clearly
and coherently for the future.
It's very exciting.
I think Sacred Rok
is serious fun.
I love serious fun.
That's what climbing
has been to me.
You had to take it very serious,
the environment you were in.
If you didn't pay
attention, the gravity
is just going to take you.
There's a couple of our
elders standing there.
You can see one of them.
I help out in the
native community.
That's been a huge
opportunity for me
to get that extended
education as a human being
and bring me back into my
indigenous reality as a human
being from the earth.
And I like one of the statements
our elders had threw out
the other day.
"You know, they have
their universities,
but we have our universe."
I was like, whoa.
That's a statement.
Because when these guys talk,
they just say it to the point.
"You got to appreciate water."
OK.
That's it.
Got to appreciate water.
"Got to work together."
That's it.
We're working together.
I mean, they call the shots.
And in that
community, the elders
are regarded as the say-so.
That's a nice picture.
This is our group, juvenile
hall walking along the river.
Beauty, beauty, beauty.
So beautiful.
And I hope that as
we're all in this room
right now that we can see
the beauty in ourselves--
the incredible phenomena
of a human body.
And it's designed
after the earth.
Don't they say that
the world is covered
with something like 70% water?
And we're mirroring that.
We have that much water in us.
I heard these things.
Maybe there's just
someone making it up.
So this is the environment
I'm coming from.
This is the environment
I know I'm connected to.
And we bring our kids up here.
This is right outside that camp.
This is about 200
feet from that camp
that I was saying I stay at.
And these boys
went around here--
I think I counted 65 times.
They'd run up, and they'd slide
down the water, a little rock.
And they'd fall.
And they'd go by going.
Every time, they would
smile when they ran around.
It was the greatest
thing you could ever see.
So this book-- we have
some here for you guys.
It's called "Voice
from the Inside Out."
When I was being asked a
lot, are you seeing results
with these guys--
and I said, well,
yeah, every time we're together,
we enjoy each other's company.
We're building a
friendship based on, again,
trust, respect, appreciation.
And then Kenji came
to a class meeting.
And we call our class meetings
"Mission: I'm Possible."
Because I doubled for Tom Cruise
in "Mission: Impossible 2."
And I was shown a clip
to the kids in class.
And as I was looking at
this clip, I'm going,
man, it's not even real.
It's like Hollywood and
it costs $80 million.
That's pretty neat and all that.
But after the clip,
I said, you guys,
this is "Mission: Impossible,"
to get out of this situation.
And then the teacher
said, let's start a club.
We can call it
"Mission: Impossible."
But the kids changed it around
to say, let's call it "Mission:
I'm Possible" and "Mission:
Accomplished" when you get out.
So at these lunch
meetings, we have
writing prompts where
the teacher and I will
get together and
suggest a question,
like, what does
water mean to you,
what does it mean to
be human, whatever.
And then Kenji joined a class.
And I said, Kenji, what did
you think about the class?
He said, there's a lot of
creativity in that room.
That's all I needed to hear.
So then we thought, what can
we do with that creativity?
So we put it into this
book, because then they
can speak for themselves.
What's it like to be in a
jail cell, go up to Yosemite,
and be underneath waterfalls
and rainbows, do trail work,
go swimming, and then go back?
So we collected
all their writings
and let them speak
for themselves.
And we'll be able to hand
some of those out to you.
You can share them.
So it's a great honor to
represent these youngsters that
are representing all of us,
because they're following
the lead that we give them.
If we put those
iPhones in their hands,
if we put the computer
in their hands,
then what are they
going to do with it?
How do they know how to
really use it responsibly?
You see that girl carrying
those little buckhorns?
I don't know if there's
another picture.
It was so funny, man.
There was some tourist
that found one,
and then they gave it to us.
And I said, let's go see if
we can find the other one.
What are the chances of
finding the other one?
We did.
We did find the other one.
Here's one of the guys.
He was saying that
this picture, it's
like a choice which way
you're going to go in life.
And you've got those cells,
and you've got this nature.
But it's an honor.
And through our diverse
group at Sacred Rok--
Kenji's colleague
was Brian Cooley.
And Nancy also worked
in social service,
so it opened up
doors quite easily,
I could say, to get
into juvenile hall,
to show our film
"Return to Balance"
and start a relationship
for the last eight years.
And we want to keep
going somewhere with it.
We want to take it so when they
do get out of juvenile hall,
they have a place to go.
Because once they have
that ankle bracelet on,
it's very difficult
as a teenager
to not be tempted to go
over to your buddy's house
that might be a known gang
member or whatever it is.
And then they're
hauled right back.
And we all know that
it's a business.
We all know there's profit
being made off these industries.
So we're not saying
we're for it, against it.
We're just trying to find
the healing and the potential
of that energy to be
used in a positive way
to help society
and help our kids.
So I think the
future of Sacred Rok
is to mirror these
juvenile halls
and have other places
in safe locations
to get the right education,
the right skills,
and then come back
out into society
to be what one of our elders
said we need to become.
Helpers, healers, and menders.
And they're ready to
do it, I'm telling you.
They are ready.
They don't want any of this.
Like Lamar was
saying, they just were
born in these circumstances,
rough situations.
But they're being mined
now for their energy
to create jobs for other people.
That's the hard look at it.
I'm just trying to be honest
as I can through my experience
and what I'm observing.
So I think the future is to
get those guys out of there,
go somewhere else, and have
different ways of being
educated and to contribute
to our communities.
Huge potential.
And probably a company like
this that could eventually
wrap their mind
around it could just
fan off some of that energy
that they call money,
and we could start
to work together
on that future for the kids.
What a thought, huh?
That's how I think.
Because when I started
climbing, people
said, you can't a way
of life through that.
Even Kenji said I couldn't
have planned my life.
But I think I was
planning it all the time
with my imagination.
Because the power of
imagination can attract things
that you would really
want, if you're sincere.
I was very sincere about
wanting to climb rocks.
But now I'm very
sincere about this.
There she is with
those little horns.
And you know, everyone
responds to nature
so well because it is a healer.
These kids would jump in
the river if it was snowing.
They love to be in the water.
That's our Fern Spring
we go to all the time.
That's the one I drove
my motorcycle past
and broke my leg.
And ever since then, I've
stopped at that spring
to pause for a minute before
I go in to Yosemite Valley.
And this is a beautiful
environment, this waterfall,
too.
And I went up there many
times to get some pictures
of that last light.
And to hear that water hitting
the granite slabs below,
it just does something to you.
There's a song out there,
and that song, I think,
evokes the memory
of our DNA that
goes back in time to
know how we're connected
to all this beautiful world.
So again, can you
imagine my privilege
to be in this environment
for the last 45 years
and just to humbly try
to make sense of it
to share with the
next generation
so that they can have the same
kind of experience or a better
experience?
So this is some of the
things we're looking at
to extend our possibilities.
We need to get
some transportation
to go pick the kids up.
Because we've said, just ride
the bus up, we'll pay for it.
But it's hard.
You've got to go pick them up.
It's set at whatever.
Saturday at 8:00, meet at
this corner; we'll get you.
And if you think about it-- and
we do some more of this stuff,
the numbers--
it costs about $90,000 a year
to keep a guy incarcerated.
And I don't even know what
budget we're working on.
Maybe I can get Nancy to
speak to this a little bit.
So that's some of our
story right there.
And if there was some
questions, that would be nice.
Or I could ask our
Chairperson Nancy to come up,
or Kenji Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: What are some of the
long term changes you've been
able to initiate in those kids?
RON KAUK: That I've
seen with them?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RON KAUK: It's an ongoing
respect that we have.
This is why I'm saying we
need to build the bridge when
they're out.
Because when they're there,
we're together all the time,
like once a week.
Could be for a year.
And then we go to the
Facebook and we're
chatting back and forth.
And the guys will send
me these positive notes.
And so we still have
a dialogue going on.
And that shows me that
we've made a connection.
Because really, I think
we're trying to operate
like an extended family.
We relate to each
other like that.
So that's what I've seen.
Mainly, I've seen
the respect that
comes from them and the
willingness to work together.
When people say the
word hope or whatever,
it shows me the
possibilities of,
if we can reach out and give a
helping hand, they'll take it.
But we have to start
thinking bigger.
Because for the last eight
years, I've been going there
and they've been coming to
Yosemite, it's a great thing.
But like we're saying, if you
do the recidivism, a lot of them
slip right back because
the pressure is just
too much when they're
back in their communities.
And they're still young guys.
And you got older guys.
It's kind of a
challenge for them.
So I've seen it in a personal
relationship-- very strong,
very positive.
And then on the other part of
the reality of the environment
that they're still staying
in, it's very difficult
to get out of it.
And so I know a lot of our guys
have gone on to adult prison,
too--
not all.
I don't even know what--
we haven't necessarily
done the numbers on that.
But that's why we know we
have to make the next step.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
being here, by the way.
It's really awesome
to listen to you.
When you get out there with
the kids for the first time,
what's it like for you?
What have you found is most
maybe effective to build
a bond and a connection
in those first few days?
RON KAUK: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because I
haven't done this.
I would think maybe you
have something in your mind
or you have a program
or something that you
want to get across.
Or maybe it's not.
I don't know.
I'd love to think about it.
RON KAUK: That's
a great question.
When I first went to juvenile
hall and I was talking to kids
and the one guy goes,
man, they're not sure if--
they don't get you.
They're not sure what you want.
I don't want anything.
I didn't want
anything from them.
I just want to be together.
And I think that sets the stage
in why we say nature's way,
education in nature's way.
There's a natural
way for us to be.
So if I'm meeting
you-- how are you?
How do you do?
And then we're checking
each other out,
like, what's your
interest or what's this.
So what I'll do right off
the bat is, here's a pack,
here's some water and food.
Let's go.
We just start walking.
But I can usually size
them up and think,
where's a good place to walk.
Because I know the place
so well, what kind of day
it is, where the
people might be,
I want to walk in
certain places.
It inspires them.
So you're letting them see
it first and feel it and not
have necessarily an adult
tell you how to think
and how to feel.
So that's why we
say we facilitate
the ceremony of nature.
So that's what's so
beautiful about being there
all these years is I
kind of know where to go
and when to go.
And then we'll strike up
just a little conversation.
So if you have some of
the other chaperones here,
we're all just walking along
in a normal set like normal.
And we start to visit on
whatever topic is interesting.
And then we could stop.
And they'll be
underneath El Capitan.
And they'll say, have
you climbed that?
And I go, yeah.
Really?
And then I might have
a story about being
up there in a snowstorm
and just wanting to get off
the face of that rock
and saying, oh god, just
get me off this
face of the rock.
I'll never do another bad
thing in my life again.
You know?
Because there's thunderclouds.
And they're like, wow.
So I think the cool thing
is I get some respect, which
is an honor.
Because I've
climbed these rocks.
So they're kind of
intrigued by this story.
But I don't force
anything on them.
Because there's a certain thing
about showing respect and not
forcing yourself on someone.
And they're dealing with
that a lot in their lives.
Because like I said, they're
locked up in that room.
But this goes for any kids--
Boys and Girls Club,
foster care, all of them.
Just respect them for who
they are and the intelligence
that they have to
share how they feel.
So we're basing a lot
on just how we feel.
It's flipping it around.
We want to respond
to how we feel
and be able to talk about
how we feel and feel
trusted to do that.
So I'm always amazed when
we have our writing prompts.
And everyone will stand up
and read it in their own way.
This is how I felt
up there that day.
And you've got a
rough bunch, too.
But we keep the respect.
That's why we say we're based
on respect, because they
want to start teasing
a little bit, maybe.
But we all kind of
recognize that we're
making this commitment
with each other
based on respect and then the
opportunity to go to Yosemite
and the opportunity
to have food together.
But I think a magic in
the healing part of it
is because we're just
so respectful and--
what would be the word?
It's a nurturing thing.
And the challenge of that is,
it's hard to write that down
on paper.
We had struggles
with some work groups
because it's like, what
are you guys doing?
We're going for a walk.
At what time?
When everybody's ready.
So I think we all like that.
That's why we all
need vacations, right?
We're like, man,
this clock is going
to drive me right off
the edge of the world.
So we get up there and
we get on nature's time.
And that's why I'm trying to get
all of us back to nature time.
You shouldn't have to
work more than half a day.
How fun is it to be here
and say stuff like this?
[LAUGHTER]
Because i know we all
feel it, but we all
are making sacrifices
because we have to survive.
We need a job.
And there's nothing
wrong with having a job.
But like I say, the
philosophy of Akido
is to take energy and
guide it to the future.
So how do we want this
to play itself out
in long-term thinking,
like the next 100 years?
I mean, this whole Silicon
Valley thing has been how long?
Not that long.
We're talking about the
history of California
is only a few hundred years.
Amazing how fast
it's all moving.
And it's cool.
It is.
It's a phenomena we're in.
But with that phenomena,
where are we going to end up?
And what is our responsibility
as humans being created,
put here in this earth
to experience life?
What is our
responsibility, our ability
to respond to the
story we're in?
So Sacred Rok is
taking responsibility
to respond to the situation
that our kids have been put in.
Just for the sake of
staying incarcerated,
just that alone, is such
an interesting thing
to be involved in.
But I can see nothing
but potential, a future
to get those kids out of there
and do something positive
with the power that they have,
the creativity they have,
the heart that they have
that actually put themselves
in that situation.
Man, they're going through
some serious rites of passage.
So if they can get through
that, they'll excel.
So it's a lot to, like I
said, wrap our minds around.
But I try not to overthink
if I can help it.
My new thing is try to think
from here and feel from here.
I'm trying to get
that language going.
Some say the longest journey is
between the mind and the heart.
I think we used to be in our
heart more as indigenous people
that we all are, have been.
And then we got up to here.
And now we're so
powerful in our intellect
that it's causing a little
confusion for the heart.
So maybe it's the middle.
Maybe we've got to get
back to the middle.
But like I say, what a
place to be saying this.
But the matter of fact is
we're all human beings,
and our kids are human beings.
And they're being subjected
to a lot of challenges.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
again for being here.
Could you talk about how you
got started in the program
and how you started
the program in general?
Just your inspiration
and things like that?
RON KAUK: Yeah.
Thank you.
One of our other board members
is named Steve Shackleton.
He's the former Chief Ranger
of Yosemite National Park,
former Chief Ranger of all
national parks in America.
And we've been good
friends forever.
And Steve and I will
take off on talks kind
of like we're having right
now, but just between us two.
And we come from these
different kind of realms,
but we have the same connection
intimately to Yosemite.
Because he grew up there
as a kid, and his dad
was head of law
enforcement there.
So he said to me in
one of our walks,
you should really meet
this guy Kenji Hakuta
who's sitting in the back of the
room that's part of our board
now.
And I said, that would be great.
And then I finally did
meet Kenji briefly.
But then, actually, Kenji
was on a solo backpack trip.
And he stopped by a
place called Tioga Pass
Resort at the top of the
Sierras, just outside Yosemite.
And he left me his number.
And he said, "I look
forward to talking to you.
Maybe there's a project of some
kind we can work together on."
He left that message for
me at Tioga Pass Resort.
I did not get that message
until the next year
because the place shut
down due to winter.
And when I went there
for the first time,
they said, hey, Ron,
there's a message for you.
I said, this is--
whatever year-- last year.
So when I went to the phone,
as soon as I could I dialed it.
Hey, Kenji.
It's Ron.
He goes, yeah, I was
wondering if you'd ever call.
I go, yeah, sorry, I
just got the message.
He goes, well, it's
funny you're calling now,
because I'm buying food
right now at the store
to come up to Yosemite.
And I go, OK, can we talk?
He came to my house.
We sat for hours
across from each other,
talking about all
the possibilities
of what we might do.
Then we ended up taking a walk
up one of my favorite trails
up above the Wawona Tunnel
with Nancy, his wife.
And we started
considering what would it
be like just to bring kids
out here and let them see it
in their own way?
We could do this thing
about facilitating
the ceremony of nature.
They said, yeah, we
should do something.
Nancy worked with foster
care and our social service
in Merced.
So within a few weeks, we had--
I don't remember how many
kids-- at least 12 or--
WOMAN: 18.
RON KAUK: 18.
A group walking up that trail.
And then with Nancy's
help-- because Kenji said,
you haven't met my wife Nancy.
She'll get things going for us.
We were a nonprofit
status within some months,
as I recall.
So then we established
ourselves a nonprofit.
And then we came over
to juvenile hall.
We showed this film.
And as we went into
that place, we came out.
I asked Kenji in
the parking lot,
what did you think about
that meeting with the kids?
He said, well, I think
we're getting warmer
to the idea of what we're doing.
So it just came about.
But it was in my mind
for years to do something
that would benefit others.
Because I think it was
in my subconscious mind
that the adults
helped me at a time.
And maybe it was coming
up to my conscious,
saying, well, it's
time for me to do that.
And that's getting
back to these thoughts
over years of how you
attract the possibilities
and the people to do something.
And I think that's
why you're all here
working with these guys.
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]